Humanity once believed we were Gods
with what this planet now faces they
will believe again
eternals assembled what's the plan
fight
hi I'm Savita from gate culture in
Singapore how are you Salva I am good
very happy to be talking to you great
and welcome to the MCU can I just say
you looked amazing at the premiere
yesterday thank you so much thank you
now I want to know what were your first
thoughts when you finally put on your
superhero costume I mean
you're a Marvel Superhero yeah it was
very strange because make me want to cry
and I was not expecting that and then I
realized that
I was putting that
superhero outfit
for
so many women you know that
Whenever there was something that was
bigger than life we were never included
we were never included you know and so
I felt that it was very meaningful
that's including middle-aged women I
understood that this moment was bigger
than me and I felt very humble that it
was me who got to
step into
this costume that represents maybe a new
era
for sure and I'm and I'm glad that it's
you too now during the press conference
um you said that you did your own stunts
so what was that like the preparation
the training
I've been doing my own stunts my entire
career
and I just kind of say
I was proud
at the beginning but I'm even more proud
now that I can still do it
um yes and uh
I didn't have
stance like Angelina you know my sons
because the the Eternal side divided in
two groups the ones that have
superpowers
for
you know fighting and War and the ones
that have other kinds of superpowers
that can be used but in a more original
way and I'm one of those so my
superpower is healing yes uh so I didn't
have a strong
but I did have some some good ones I
even have a fight with Angelina herself
herself
um it was a lot of fun it was a lot of
fun we watched a movie we know what
happens to Ajax we're not going to talk
about it in case people haven't watched
it but where do you see yourself next in
the MCU do you see yourself in a sequel
another movie or even Disney plus like
what are you what are your hopes moving
forward from this
well the thing about the Marvel universe
is not only you can be in the sequel and
in the next sequel but you can
navigate towards
another Marvel Universe you know
area yeah a whole other group of people
although I will be missing my group of
people and because we've been around for
7 000 years yeah
um
there's infinite possibilities of where
you will find Ajax next
I love that I'm so excited to see thank
you so much thank you so much love to
Singapore
[Music]